you
fifteen players only Queen masters in
there all right this is a created
tournament a 30-minute tournament
one-minute chess and we had a late
joiner good to see I am forever a nun
hop on in there
I believe forever anon was playing in a
tournament I thought so did he withdraw
that and jump in this one I love it
right to see
clean exchange it's one of my favorite
lines this one here
okay good oh I just dropped my beer shop
it's not my favorite line oh man
he moved oh that's a bummer that's a
bummer
ah not cool I might be able to starve
some trouble somehow with the rook here
we're not really playing it the best
possible way
but it'll be enough it'll definitely be
enough I have a time edge but that's
that's about it
he likes
got to cancel out that night it's too
strong
prepare to meet this with the push give
that Bishop a kick oh it's going to hurt
it's going to hurt
fortunately I could track that pond down
yeah however
those pawns are pushing
fast
yes they are
hmm
yeah that works seven seconds
ah man it would have been nice if I
could you know be playing this where I'm
not down a piece
you
ah man
ah the bishop moved in my bishop was
under fire
and that's not the first time I've gone
for that I've dropped a bishop like that
before
ah man
ah so kitty chess like it's so kitty
just like my pawns not moving
mmm I want that Bishop back I want that
game back so bad my LightSquared Bishop
back to tournament what a strong win
that one was all right we got to
we're back in it we're back in it we got
to go fishing it's the only way to fight
back is to go fishing oh I was too quick
to throw out the line there not anyone
out that means let's play chess you
fishermen okay get developed break
keep your structure intact question that
guy all right I got the darts for Bishop
am i dropping any pieces I don't think
so and you get the C file to play with
oh no that's best Knights going to sink
into b6 my pawns playing a good game
here yeah definitely pushing me around
how to challenge this night
he's kind of a problem
we may have something similar in this
game no I think they should have done
that let's get my bishop on the long
diagonal this problem could be a target
my queen is going to come back over to
c7 let's scoop up that pond I don't
think it's too far out of her way let's
give him boot
could get them off of beef or he's going
to jump in there I don't want to take
them if he does that it's not he's not
captured could take their I get to
recapture wits check let's just take the
night out and enter to challenge the
rook now I got my background covered I
have a flight square they much they
Mouse slip there
let's push them push them home make it
one threat they resigned back to
tournament all right we got four because
of that non game I'm still in there I
have fire now top is forever and on the
round one beating that I took he's got
five fire a lot of fire in here 29
players I see a tricky Knights in there
easy
d for
let's let's throw @h pod at black I
think this is a nice move for bullet
plenty of plenty of good things to be
trying alright let's have that pollen
act as a thorn mmm that's a piece I have
that covered enough maybe they resign
all right I'll grab a pond develop and
defend for I'm looking at castling
queenside be pinned I can take here with
the night pin non f6 and then here I
could take
there's my opponent get out of the pin I
could go queen bee for as well let's
take that pawn knight is pinned
threatening to take and then a follow up
with the fork Queen takes it's natural
but it's not good there's a queen
let's take with the paw my Queens
defending the rook they resign back to
tournament got 8 23 minutes and change
I should be I should be able to get
another shot at forever and on
we'll see he's in a game right now
against some crazy guy about our bombs
okay oh really
the budapest gambit alrighty then I'm
fine with just giving that pond back
completing developments I try that rook
a6 move now mmm let's go here stop night
before I can use a flight square
hmm you know let's go for it now why not
oh here keep my rook on the a file to
defend on my opponent I think I want to
get it going for this
that bishops close to trap no
no here's no good because I could take
with my bishop let's just double
I have to try not here I think my bishop
is soon to be trapped
is that Bishop for not trapped he's a
cook bishop probably have to sack here
no sacking over on the queenside so how
do we enter I guess we'll start with
Queen on c6 let's give a check
maybe my night into f5 some trades how
about a knight on f4 it's maybe even
better rook on d5 now let's walk up some
exchanges
hmm let's get my knight here first
and then actually scrab upon
there's no G for move my knight is
secure let's grab another count another
pawn what is it exactly was I about to
call it a clone oh no I didn't want to
do that I promise I was a mouse slipper
yes I got him back
check where's the mate where's my time I
got the Queen not mate though huh
why am I not able to move fast huh
make sure you get all the phones I don't
confidence in my mouse it's failing me
I'm gonna get it holder down a time
point 600 mid whoo I don't know my
heart's beating faster than normal
20 minutes in change I'm eight back now
I'm six I can't do math would it be the
first time bad math when I play bullet
watch out for the bad math Queen c7 Oh
get out of my house this is my house
my side of the board shoe let's move
forward and break in the center why not
the king is still there we're going to
take and then follow up with the fancy
Fork
any fancy for maybe not right away let's
go there first and maybe go for a pin if
the Queen still on the e-file she's not
this feels right followed up with queen
C for leading to me whoa
how about that let's go here that's me a
bishop would have done the trick as well
twenty-two 1612
see in a game is in a game get him
Socko track him down
all right 31 players in this one Queen
master is in fourth
we got quick legs on my heels krispy 99
all right a nimzo-indian a an unprovoked
capture on seat three all right we're
going to go for efore and Bishop to g5
and now we're on up be five let's keep
that pin
it's Castle v5 on board got to go with
g5 and now we're going to look to break
down these dark squares immediately
we're there and I think I could already
look at moves like Brooke up six mmm
let's take a timeout to capture aa clean
takes g5 though
okay now we're cooking
I guess we could give a check I want to
keep the cleans on but okay
felt like I could have a maid there
still good course and I don't know line
up some discovery
okay another discovery difficult to
avoid that
let's take the rook throw a knight check
in there scrap that and then take the
bishop next to Eve and attack the bishop
got the W they resign 26:20 get them
quick legs he's in a game again still
plenty of time not even at the halfway
point yet six back three behind his
queen master
all right queen master on board all
righty
I don't want to take that pawn let's
just keep that tension for a little bit
all right Knight remains in the pin
let's keep it
all right now we'll take here and just
complete development
take with the pawn get the LightSquared
Bishop Soph and then play with the
better bishop
King up
let's just centralize I want my knight
on e4 I think now let's let's clamp down
on the light square some I shouldn't
have pulled my ruck off of the h-file I
guess that's what they're going for
all right I'm going to try to work
around that night let's get back over
here get to the seventh rank or even how
about how about a night here maybe let's
push push I could take on a six trying
to clamp down on this advance night here
they're going to try come on the bishop
give me a piece there
good control here hit the bishop get on
the seventh with maybe both rooks
more pressure on the bishop it's another
piece and close to mate
vii if the rook rook takes I have a mate
too
and mate coming up very soon King is in
a box
that's going to do it back to term in 30
24 is where I stand
17:12 12 called the halfway point we're
locked in there with 31 players
okay
feel like I need to get some quick kills
all right let's keep the Queen on c7
because everybody knows what I'm lining
up mmm I could take that home
h2 still still main to threat mate in to
h1 this time
these are the kind of wins I need the
quick ones they resigned back determined
34 oh he had a quick one in there I
think we're going to get paired up I
don't think he's in the game here that's
made on board
so we're going to get paired up No
batter bombs it's going to try to hunt
them down
14 minute mark
battery bombs is doing that same thing
that a budapest getting a pairing
six back
dark bastion in the chat says the poll
has arrived
it has arrived what is with these five
moves a lot of ePHI vests
all right there could be trouble right
around the corner here for black careful
black the Queen moves oh that's a
problem and I resign up apiece up on
time
okay gonna play off a piece here
what more point more ricany one get a
flight square 905 let's go and light up
five right now
Bishop f4 if allowed maybe should have
done that but they're down a piece I
could sacrifice I could do a lot of
things here this night ever moves that's
a killer supreme of it
maybe g4y not
try to get that night to budge and then
upon push
yeah that was um that was silly of me to
do it like that I wasn't really getting
anything huh
okay I'm scared a little bit they're
down on time I shouldn't be scared night
here I didn't see I'm is dropping that
pond they don't have any time
they're down on time vac determined
38:32 I'm still six back he's in a game
that just finished here we go let's see
if I could hang it in my life square
bishop if we revisit now we're not
revisiting alright we're going to try
for an Enzo or a BOGO a BOGO on board
let's look to restrict that night clean
check no okay it's quiet little quiet
not allowing me to clamp down on their
queenside I see
flight square
knight on e4 mm-hmm
light-square bishop on d5 is what I want
try for that
even this even though I have to prune my
structure some
I can't challenge the file just yet
I have a clean check that would be a
blunder if the rook moved
hmm not sure what that move is doing ooh
hey grab that pond
let's come back here
Oh
let's give this now let's get out of a
pin
let's go here
and I feel like I should have some kind
of a mate maybe
24 seconds
okay this should be very good for me
and I get the bishop if the rook is
captured
on my knight on f4
this is tremendous
let's give some checks
that night out of there
where's the mates
that's close to me
that mate is this me
oh no I drop my clean
oh they're down at time Oh ton of people
are typing right now I just I know it I
know it
didn't he at move X have insert move
yeah
there were seven at least seven mates so
feel free to type out one of them pretty
sure I'm pretty sure there was a mate or
two or seven Wow
there had to be had to be all right we
got him back we got him back all right
you're gonna want to hang out of that
deep on he's he's sort of important sort
of important I don't know I don't know I
could use a flight Square stop this pond
from going into attack mode
got some weaknesses should try to pounce
on them
all right rook takes rook can't take
here just yet
takes rook in-betweener let's support
him and have a connected passed pawn and
be happy with that can't go here maybe
you can because there is King to f8 to
defend I definitely want to keep a pawn
defending this guy I want a light square
bishop exchange any exchange I'll take
really clean exchange sure get over here
track down the c5 pawn start with the
check that Kings getting a little too
active I don't like it
hmm let's go here first yeah he's a
little bit too active I don't like that
let's try this ah I have to dislodge
that bishop he's good is he dead oh um I
guess I'm gonna have to move my rook
keep going no mates
sneaky sneaky let's give a check there
down on time okay wooof 40
forty forty but I have fire that's the
edge that I have fire thirty five a few
more entered let's see if I get next get
them batter bombs knock them out
let's take a quick peek they've only
played two games okay here we go
why am I playing the slob I don't know
okay
I have to go for something different
4040
mmm let's see if they take I want to get
any five
let's take here first Bishop takes I
have Knight takes Knight with check
uh-huh got a piece let's just open up
the Queen side immediately
there we go I should have played a five
open it up some more Bishop takes pawn
in some cases right um I was going to
give up the exchange just to get some
activity and stop any push any further
push I could have probably just moved my
King off of this file instead of Bishop
back covering this square how about my
knight here and it seems sensible knight
on e6 and then a sacrifice on d4 let's
try four
we're almost there he takes pawn maybe
I'll take with the bishop I want to have
a knight here now we have this with a
fork and a time edge
some more trades can make use of v8
without the bishop around now
and just some more trades rook activity
there down on time 44-42 we both have
fire I have a two point lead
he hasn't berserk tin this game
all right let's see less than five got
it I'm going with the Slav again all
right I get my bishop outside the pawn
chain though
give me the H file to play with okay in
a council kingside how long can you hold
off without castling we're going to find
out we're going to test it I should have
gone with 94 maybe sooner when I was
ready drop a piece
I want my knight on e4 and then play f6
I want to try to push through with this
idea get rid of this Knight push I have
g3 and then maybe II to get rid of this
Knight gotta go there don't have any
fancy moves okay
tonight right there soon my night strap
no I got Queen here
Kings going to be running for his life
now Queen here and I'm ready to pick up
the knight in two moves Oh can't get
there now I can insist try to at least
hang on
got the night
and probably just get to the G file the
pawn takes here we go probably a capture
on g2 they resigned back determined
fairly quick 4842 we're going to get
paired up again
well is he still in the game
huh no three minutes left I have a
six-point lead I like it Oh he just won
though oh he's got fire it's gonna come
down to this we're gonna be paired up
again he just finished oh man
37 players 48 46
let me at him let me at him here we go
it's for all the marbles
most likely okay
oh this is a isn't this a problem
all right I do not mind this physician
I know I've doubled pawns but I'm going
to go Queen side a pawn is pinned
let's get to the G file and probably a
pin is nice
still nap in
still in a pin let's back up Pont push I
have this
I want to tuck my king in whoo got some
material
oh that can't I can't be too good
let's keep that pin
there's not an easy way out of that
I don't think so
take care first
and now we could take here
and then here let's keep that pin
keep the pins
still in a pin
now we take
and then activate
18 seconds though time
where is the time to
upon
oh they grabbed one
just want to push through
don't drop your rook whatever you do
don't drop your rook
I have a time lead as well this is
looking good this is looking good
who
Oh a big sigh of relief
that's what who meant at that point 5246
who man pins pin town that was a killer
bishop there on g3 I guess we're not
going to get another pairing
52:46 35 20 seconds yeah I don't see
another another pairing
oh man
yeah ten seconds left that's going to do
it
it's able to get them back from that
little speed bump in the beginning
dropping that bishop
confetti
and 5246 forever 9 35 33
clean master making the podium 37
players in all
page to light to New York I see
tricky nights
and that's all the pages john madden
they're playing a game maybe catching
the tournament late
all right to the 36 of you
use all
okay